112 est ce que vous savez ce que c'est
c'est le savait non non c'est pas ça non
je sais pas ça numéro de téléphone c'est
sa numéro d'urgence sans doute mais
alors pourquoi je suis plus à celle des
appels d'urgence mais quels numéros
appeler en cas d'accident de douze noms
ou le 8 ou 9 ou 10 je sais pas 18
pompiers samu 15 noms et 18 17
c'est vrai qu'on a pas beaucoup
l'opportunité de faire le 112 parce
qu'au niveau national on fait le 18
alors 18 ou 112 c'est ici au centre de
secours de besançon que son reçu les
appels des deux numéros une mission
essentielle assurée par ces
sapeurs-pompiers 365 jours par an et 24
heures sur 24
une femme de 55 ans qui a chuté sur sur
dans la rue on va essayer tout de suite
de déterminer si une urgence vitale
quand on est faits visés par des
questions sur la conscience si la
personne est consciente
si la personne est l'équipe d'une
détresse respiratoire ou non et si elle
a une hémorragie importante 6,8 à notre
questionnement à mèche encore sur un
malaise
on va donc proposer ce motif de départ
hélas le logiciel va nous permettre nous
donner l'engin adapté au départ est le
plus proche des lieux de l'intervention
accident de la circulation incendie ou
encore noyade
au total 35 mille dossiers ont été
traités dans le seul département du
doubs en 2020 être l'occasion de
rappeler que le 112 est encore souvent
utilisé à mauvais escient le 112 ça
représente seulement 20% des appels
d'urgence
quatre appels sur 5 réalisé sur le 112
ne sont pas d'urgence sont rattachés
soit du renseignement soit dépannage
routier soit des fausses manipulations
et les primordial que ce numéro du sang
2 soit dédiée à l'urgence le 112 est
gratuit depuis un téléphone fixe ou
portable
l'an dernier on estime qu'il a été
composé plus de 150 millions de fois en
europe